since you're wearing a space actually
let me ask guys so i didn't realize that
i apologize yeah
so crew dragon the first uh crude
mission
out into space since the
the space shuttle and just
by first time ever by a commercial
company
i mean it's an incredible accomplishment
i think but it's also just an
incredible it inspires imagination
amongst people that this
is the first step in a long like
vibrant journey of humans into space oh
yeah
so what do you what are your how do you
feel is this you know is this exciting
to you
yeah it is i think it's great the idea
of seeing it basically done by smaller
entities instead of by governments i
mean
it's a it's a heavy collaboration
between spacex and nasa in this case
but moving in the direction of not
necessarily requiring an entire country
and its government to make it happen
but that you can have um uh something
closer to a single company doing it
we're not there yet
because it's not like they're
unilaterally saying like we're just
shooting people up into space
um it's just a sign that we're able to
do more powerful things with smaller
groups of people
uh i find that inspiring innovate
quickly
i hope we see people land on mars in my
lifetime do you think we will
i think so i mean i think there's a ton
of challenges there right like radiation
being kind of
the biggest one and i think there's a
ton of people who uh
look at that and say why why would you
want to do that
let's let the robots do the science for
us but i think there's an
enough people who are like genuinely
inspired about broadening like the
worlds that we've touched
um or people who think about things like
backing up the light of consciousness
with like super long-term visions of
terraforming like as long as there's
backing up the light of consciousness
yeah the thought that uh you know if we
if earth goes to hell
we gotta have a backup somewhere um a
lot of people see that as pretty out
there and it's like not in the short
term future but
i think that's an inspiring thought i
think that's a reason to like get up in
the morning and
i feel like most employees at spacex
feel that way too
do you think we'll colonize mars one day
no idea like either agi kills us first
or if we're like allowed i don't know if
it'll take loud
well like honestly it takes it would
take such a long time
like okay you might have a small colony
right something like what you see
in um the martian but not like people
living
comfortably there um but if you want to
talk about actual
like second earth kind of stuff
that which that's just like way far out
there and the future moves so fast that
it's hard to predict like we might just
kill ourselves before that even becomes
viable
uh yeah i mean there's there's a lot of
possibilities where it could be
just it doesn't have to be on a planet
we could be floating out in space
have uh have a have a space faring
backup solution that doesn't have uh
that doesn't have to deal with the
constraints that are planned but i mean
a plan
provides a lot of possibilities and
resources but also some constraints
yeah i mean for me for some reason it's
a deeply exciting possibility oh yeah
all of the people who are like skeptical
about it or like why why do we care
about going to mars
it's like what makes you care about
anything that's not inspiring
it's hard actually it's hard to hear
that because
exactly as you put it on a philosophical
level it's hard to
say why do anything i don't know it's
it's like the people say like
you know i've been doing like an insane
challenge last 30 something days
your pull-ups and to pull up some
push-ups and like
you know a bunch of people are like
awesome you're insane but awesome
and then some people are like why why do
anything
i i don't know at this there's a calling
it's uh
i i'm with jfk a little bit it's because
we do these things because they're hard
there's something in the human spirit
that says like
same with like a math problem there's
something you fail once
and it's like this feeling that you know
what i'm not going to back down from
this
there's something to be discovered in
overcoming this thing
well so what i like about it is um and i
also like this about the moon missions
sure is kind of arbitrary but you can't
move the target so
you can't make it easier and say that
you've accomplished the goal
and when that happens it just demands
actual innovation right
like protecting humans from the
radiation in space
on the flight there while there heart
problem demands innovation
you can't move the goal post to make
that easier almost certainly the
innovations required for things like
that will be relevant in a bunch of
other domains too
um so like the idea of doing something
merely because it's hard
it's like loosely productive great but
as long as you can't move the goal posts
there's probably going to be these
secondary benefits that
like we should all strive for yeah i
mean
it's hard to formulate the mars
colonization problem as something that
has a deadline which is the problem but
if there was a deadline
then the amount of things we would come
up with
by forcing ourselves to figure out how
to colonize
that place would be just incredible
you